hi everyone thank you for joining us
today and a very warm welcome to the
fourth episode of studio sml sessions a
match made in design
this event is presented by the press
room and is supported by the design
singapore council and the national
design center i'm felicia from the
design singapore council and i will be
your mc for today
today's studio sml session a match made
in design will feature three design
practices that are fronted by husband
and wife teams
each practice will be taking some time
to share a little more about themselves
their working dynamics and key projects
in the first half of the session and we
will close things off with a panel
discussion and an audience q a segment
in the later half
and with that it's now my absolute
pleasure to present our speakers for
today
first up we have victor lee and
jacqueline yeoh co-founders of ply
studio architects
ply studio architect is a design driven
architectural practice based in
singapore that operates across all
building skills within the fields of
interiors architecture and urbanism
joining us is also timo wong co-founder
and one half of studio juju a
singapore-based design office which
designs with fresh perspectives
emotional connection and a thoughtful
consideration of human experiences
and last but definitely not the least
representing outer edit we have director
xiamin tan
outer edit is a branding and creative
agency based in singapore that helps
brands create meaningful and impactful
stories to connect with the community in
unexpected ways
so without further ado i will now be
handing the time over to kelly chang a
moderator for today to officially kick
start the session kelly is also the
brains behind studio sml and the
creative director and founder of the
press room a publishing and design
consultancy so kelly over to you please
hi
thanks
uh so
welcome to another session of studio sml
talk session this top session is an
extension of our schedule xml platform
that hopes to document stories of local
creatives and this talk session which
hopefully will become physical soon is
actually
what we hope to bring the design
community together for discussions uh
and also discuss about uh our design
community
so anyway um
without much further ado i want to
introduce the first uh first husband and
wife team for today they are also my
very good friends so really happy to
have them uh pie studio architects uh
they are husband and wife team uh victor
and jack
also my drinking khaki hello
they have been exploring methodologies
of how a two-person team can scale up to
handle big projects
um find out why they make the choice to
manage systems of work rather than
manage people in crafting their
architecture so over to you uh jack and
dick
right um sharing the talk with me today
is my partner jacqueline
as felicia rightly
mentioned just now based on the short
introduction um
that applies to your architects and we
are based in singapore uh working across
interiors architecture and urbanism
um our name ply actually is a bit of a
misconception because it's not really to
do so much with the material plywood but
it really stands for you know
the practice of lee and yo which are our
family names
and really to trying to get into the
whole idea of applying a trade and
suggesting also a return uh to the
fundamentals of practice and also to
hone our craft in building
um perhaps a little bit about ourselves
um to ground the the work that we'll be
showing later
um we will be showing a series of four
projects to hopefully try and discuss
some of the earlier mentioned uh systems
of design and methodologies of design
that kelly mentioned um we
we
started basically with the kind of our
representation
as one of singapore's 20 creatives in
the 2008 um venice benelli which is
entitled super garden so each of the
presenters were told to bring an object
to be exhibited we didn't want to just
take like a model of a complete model we
really wanted to
bring across to the table a series of
little objects that could also
cross-reference you know our own
projects so we stripped apart one of the
elements from our own interiors project
and then together with some fragments of
the other projects that we have we
decided to create a picnic
basket and hopefully to extend that
across the garden environment and to try
and elicit some sort of a conversation
going on
um
today we have uh we have basically grown
uh in terms of uh
you know our experience and you know in
terms of our kind of working with
various skills and genres and typologies
or projects to encompass um
institutional to residential to private
homes and so on and so forth
how we work really we are grounded by
three kind of anchors and key activities
positioning research and design and we
are always interested to examine some of
the subsequent back and forth between
these three
aspects
which really really can be seen to be
evident in our works
which we will talk about later through
the four projects
um perhaps as a starting point um one of
our very early projects which was done
in association with the firm that we
we used to be part of is the project
for a
housing project in
sanya in hainan island
um so basically looking at this kind of
models you know model in terms of the
production of
the design through to models very rough
models and then the finished model here
it's really grounded in our kind of
attempt to break down uh information and
to re-look at data
uh and in doing so um trying to create
the building forms out of there
i mean in this case the entire design
and research
in terms of the data gathering also
started from an excel spreadsheet where
we tried to you know look at how
conventional towers can be redistributed
across
an entire kind of horizontal strata and
then to use the numbers to give us to
give rise to the building forms and
making the models as well was quite
interesting because we also realized
that by looking at how the
one quadrant of the building can be
reflected
uh you can really see how we are trying
to find in the way the economies of of
design and economies of scale that that
we we were trying to
talk about so in the early days um
projects like that um really really took
off from there um something smaller
where we started working um on an
interior project um for the old uh
design singapore um
you know there's like a small office in
the old makeup building looking after
the
repetition
of simple forms and objects to see how
we can use that to define space um never
really straying too far from the
original motifs looking at how
through the process of design and
construction as well as the articulating
of the final
space itself
how the forms could be remain integral
to the design
a small f and b project where
again a similar family of forms in this
case looking at a typological kind of
starting point by reimagining new uses
for simple and ubiquitous forms to then
try and define new experience modulated
in the form of these archers that we
also went through in terms of the
process of making it making models
looking at materials and then finally
looking at how it can be
built and assembled on site
and then also constructing a series of
drawings that really help to know our
builders understand the idea of the
modulations going on
um
all this work kind of culminated in 2019
where we were cordially invited by
ura to be part of the first group of
small practices that were able to
exhibit in the newly established aude
space the building the exhibition itself
was entitled building economy that was
the first time that we're trying to
establish what kind of methodology that
we've been trying to work across
could amount to
and very aptly so
the theme of the exhibition was also to
deal with
small firms and how small firms can use
their kind of creative strengths and the
way they operate in the world to project
themselves uh with bigger ideas and
eventually trying to work on larger
scale
projects so in a way this idea of
building economies somehow came along
and when we examined the process that
we've been doing we also liken it or you
know allude it to a kind of design
economy so i would like to maybe hand
over to jacqueline now who will be
discussing the first two of the projects
that we'll be sharing
hi everyone i'm jacqueline i'm just uh
going to share with you some of our
recent projects this was a recent show
gallery in
kl that was during the days when
everyone could travel easily there
it's a sales gallery for a new master
plan right smack in the middle between
klia and the city center
we wanted to use it as a means to
demonstrate our clients capabilities our
clients in this case is a very large
developer in malaysia that also does a
lot of infrastructural projects
so i think when you look at a
sort of tabula rasa in in malaysia um
for a new master plan the first building
that comes about in the new master plan
is actually a sales gallery and usually
there's like barren land throughout the
whole space so our first strategy was
how do we bring the temperature down and
how do we create a sort of context for
our building so we decided that one one
quick way to do so was to plant an urban
grid of trees
and with that to use that as well to
inform a sort of structural grid
and to also hybridize these two
landscape and construction building two
together
and with that move
um it was to try and rationalize the
structure and and the landscape
into very uh strictly four building
blocks that come together in a pinwheel
organization around uh sort of urban
sanctuary so the middle space was
supposed to be as as clean as possible
without
the sort of extraneous stuff that you
normally get in a in a sales gallery so
as we as we started the project we also
use the sort of repetition of modulated
forms to create our models and as you
can see it started with very simple
structures that are then put together
and these are some of the interior views
that we looked at
and we then built bigger and bigger
models to illustrate it to the client
and i think they were really excited
because they were also going to be the
builders for this project
so as as we went along um we realized
that actually our client also has
a building capability of the
of uh our precast factory um so this is
a the built
project already from the urban sanctuary
in the middle and to see the sort of
structural arms of the
concrete trees within the building
um we we use the opportunity of of
creating this motif of the tree form
also to talk to the structural engineers
and the mne engineers and how to
actually create a sort of a
structure that actually encompasses all
the elements that's required in the
building
so
the material and how we actually laid
out the different components of the
building
down to the finish and even how do we
actually create a very simple
instructions for the builders to to
fabricate these concrete arms um so the
the
photos on the left actually are the
typical sort of um building
prefabrication plant that the client
already had and we really used that
sort of like an industrialization to
create what we really wanted with the
sales gallery which is what you see on
the right
so through a lot of
factory visits and trying to find out
what's the most optimum way of creating
a mold a prefabrication mode and to test
it in one is to one scale
and then to finally erect it on site so
prefabrication is also a form of economy
in that sense because the entire site
from from a blank slate to what you see
on the right and and further on these
slides took maybe about three to four
months which is really really fast for
building up this skill
so
finally these are some slides of the
final
finished building
i think we were really happy because it
it first of all didn't allow for a lot
of other
um things to come into the interior
space like the m e i m and e um
components etc and then everything was
just very simply laid out and it also
allowed for the clients
models to stand out in a way
for the sales gallery so this is the
view from the interior
and then
mix is the view from the exterior
and then i think we just wanted to also
have one from the the internal courtyard
so
within this courtyard itself
the the repetition and the modularis
modular
forms of the
of the prefabricated arms are very very
visible
so some details
the interior palette is kept very muted
because i think at the end of the day it
was supposed to be more of a back
backdrop to what the client wanted to
showcase
some some edges of the building that are
seen in the daytime and the night time
finally some views of the final
building from the outside
so the next project i will talk about is
um is a school
in singapore it is uh
it is the rainbow center in queenstown
um this is done in association with the
architect circle so i think
as what kelly mentioned a lot of our
projects are also done in association
with bigger firms
firms that can handle things like
submissions and paperwork and the whole
record process so i think we we find
that way of collaboration very
interesting and also very helpful for
our small practice
for rainbow the crux was really to find
a sort of meeting ground
that
serves as a design framework because in
terms of that project itself there were
many many parties that were involved
from the client organization to the
funding organization to even the
building
building organization so based on the
clients
brief there were actually not just a
school component that was also the
fundraising component the headquarters
component and of course the teaching
component whereby they have to manage a
whole group of people to
share their knowledge of teaching
children and young adults with
disabilities so
at
the
essence of what we wanted to do was to
really reach out to those various
parties and to kind of align with the
ethos of what rainbow center represented
and to create a sort of sense of built
form and space that everyone could
subscribe to
so
the thing that we chose as a design
strategy was to break it down to
just using the unit of a classroom and
to build it up to a certain recognizable
form um through a means of addition and
subtraction and also of positioning it
on site on plan and on in section
so it helped also that there was
actually an existing building the
existing building was a very old
two-story building that was surrounding
a central courtyard so in this new uh
extension to the new building we also
wanted to keep to that um courtyard
typology
and i think um that's this this kind of
shows the sort of site context of where
the existing building used to be and the
new building
adjacent to it in terms of the size it
was very similar in scale although our
building now was four stories and then
the existing was a two-story building so
um part of the strategy was by breaking
down the units was also to see as much
as possible to return the sense of scale
in the sense of the two-storiness of the
existing building uh back to the to the
project um when we talked about that
unit of the classroom um one main
consideration was also how pedagogically
the school decided to shift from a very
monotonous classroom and uh
corridors of type into more of a cluster
so with that in mind the design of the
new school could actually be
a lot more
manipulated so it doesn't subscribe to
the to the dark corridor and classroom
type anymore it's now more of a learning
center
so as you can see from this slide um the
typical classrooms were in the light
gray and then with the move to cluster
it we are able to then allow for these
incremental floor plates shifts that
also ended up with
opportunities that are developed to
negotiate some
certain
sort of comfort level at the facade
because the majority of this building
actually faced west
so with that incremental shift we
allowed for these various elements to be
plugged in as part of the the
negotiations of the comfort level
and also in terms of the light level
coming into the building so we really
wanted this very um filtered sort of
light to come into the interior spaces
as you can see so we had a layer of
sunscreens that modulate moderated the
harsh sunlight coming in from the west
into the space itself and it also
allowed opportunities for this in
between spaces that worked very well
with the internal classrooms
you can see on these field slides
especially the saw activities that can
take place
and um
and while we were doing it there was
also of course consideration of how
actually it's going to be built
this was through conversations with our
contractors
who built many many mock-ups for
for the
for the school to to approve
so as you go along i think
this was some photos of
the model and the final slides and and
to really then go back
also to talk about the courtyards
whereby they by layering them the double
story intent of the original school is
carried through into this new school so
i'll just move on because i think we're
running out of time so we just move on
quite quickly
um
[Music]
and activities that take place are some
events that really really enliven the
whole courtyard space and
how it sits in the context of queenstown
okay okay okay
um for the next project it's actually a
project that we
wanted to see how we can be using plan
aggregations as a form of design economy
so this is actually a project that is
not in singapore it's actually in
nairobi which is a capital of kenya in
east africa
it's an project for an affordable
housing and of course
you know being a singaporean
going to africa was really
quite a unique experience for us um
looking at the culture and the context
as well but what we are trying what we
started trying to do was to try and
understand
um the kind of you know character of of
nairobi as a city also zooming out to
look at you know the comparisons between
singapore and nairobi in the kind of
global kind of context looking at the
cities themselves understanding the
built-up
and the composition of the spaces and so
on and so forth and also in particularly
looking at the issue of moto
and vehicular congestion which is
something very much present in
nairobi city and something that is also
very evident in
in singapore itself
then understanding um the kind of growth
of nairobi as a city the kind of
gentrification and densification process
it has undergone
um but and
and as a result receive out the fact
that there are also certain spaces or
certain areas in the city that have been
um left quite unforgotten quite
forgotten especially with our site as
well which is uh one of the examples of
such a
space in the city um it is actually um
in the vicinity of the airport and it's
about a 20-minute car ride out from the
city center
um
then looking in parallel with
the kind of residential
housing typologies that are evident
there and to try and see if there's a
way in which we can understand or really
break down and analyze
the kind of housing model that that is
very much prevalent and to try and see
if there's a way in which we can
import some of our own knowledge
of design and of building into
like a kind of different context that
we're used to in singapore so as you can
see in these diagrams on these
photographs and plans that the housing
model is very much driven by a
car-centric kind of environment where a
lot of the ground space is dedicated to
driveways and and parking and this is
evident in the two projects that our
client has already built so they are
really building it in the same in the
same manner in the same
model of development um compared to what
we typically see perhaps in our
public housing estates as well where you
hardly see no traces of vehicular
traffic on the ground versus what's
really really normal and evident in
nairobi city and
the unique difference of course for us
is the use of the parking the
multi-story car parking structure which
which is which is something that we
thought we could actually bring into the
context of nairobi to look at how
once the land is freed up
it can really be used to create more
meaningful kind of open spaces and
facilities that can then serve the
residents
the constraint for us was to really work
with the building floor plan of the
previous two developments that our
climate has already built and we sought
to then see how with that floor plan we
can actually create some kind of
meaningful variations by
altering the orientation and the facing
of the left and the right hand side
units which is now currently separated
by a center staircase and also to do a
one
kind of one facing out and one facing in
kind of apartment block as well with
that as a kind of typical footprint
of one floor plan we can then see how we
can string them together in the kind of
precinct level and each kind of precinct
has the kind of use of a central open
space that can be shared then looking at
kind of geometrical processes to see how
precincts can then be
um aggregated and multiplied to form um
smaller kind of centers and then to kind
of derive the entire floor plan through
this series of exercises
um and then finally just kind of ending
with a few series of images that capture
the conjugate space and then also the
spaces in between
the multi-story compound which are
heavily buffered by landscaping um last
kind of two small projects that we want
to show is the idea of design economy
equates to incremental differentiations
so this is a project for a
covered linked way in one of the
institutional schools in singapore
where we tried to
look at how you know just by kind of
creating small changes within a typical
portal shape
formed we can create um a series of you
know structural elements that span
across one end to one end and to have a
kind of continuity in describing the
design and the geometry of
of the final kind of structure which is
not unlike what we are typically used to
in the ubiquitous kind of
landscape in singapore and then finally
to really kind of look at how we can
even we can even take on the typological
kind of idea from looking at the how a
kind of
node can be kind of manifested as a
pavilion from one end to the other end
of the bridge um and then finally uh
design economy for us also the idea of
calculated repetitions so for a really
small project um in the same
campus uh really to look at how
sun shading can be created in the
library space so we started by looking
at the kind of environmental
orientations of sun and light and so on
and so forth capturing the right kind of
angles and
really pinning down what is the critical
directionalities to respect then using
that as a means to
kind of
base our design on in a very geometrical
manner how the angles of the of the of
the sunshade
really interacted with the sunlight and
to try and create the depth by creating
this kind of sectional motifs that
actually
offer some kind of deflection and
blockage of the harsh sunlight so
everything that you can see here is
divided into nine strips which are all
cut out from a single
length single row of fabric so really
just putting together nine kind of
repetitive strips together we can create
a kind of effective kind of sun shading
um for the for this library space
so um i think that's kind of brings us
to the end of the presentation so um as
you can see there's more
there's a big there's a lot of
information that has already been um
said and well very very really well put
together and we're really helped uh glad
that
we have been able to be given this
opportunity to share our work to the
studio sml platform so thanks kelly and
thanks dsg for the kind support
and then really at the end of the day
just looking at
whether or not we have been really
addressing this question of a match made
in design um we are very two different
individuals so um i'm more of the
introvert and jacqueline is more of an
extrovert and and naturally we tend to
do things a bit differently but what i
guess we're trying to show today is how
we have maybe through the years develop
a kind of operative
framework for for working such that it
becomes a process of rationalization
and plugging into the system rather than
driven by kind of our own individual
kind of
wants and desires so thank you very much
for your time
uh thanks a lot jai and vic for the
insights into your project uh good to uh
you know learn more about them and you
still need to bring me to rainbow center
yeah okay so uh thanks we are going to
move on to studio juju now
uh sudo juju is timo wong and priscilla
luke also a husband and wife team their
practice focuses on product industrial
and spatial design
they have also ventured into the rank of
art recently
a two-person team today they will share
with us how the power of two can
sometimes be much more effective than a
big team in the process of making design
so uh over to you timor
hi hello everybody hey thanks kelly for
the introduction
juju is
basically me and priscilla my wife my
partner
and um the studio has always been the
two of us we've got additional stuff
on and off we have staff and we have
some like interns working for us and our
interest is or
i would say sometimes a little bit of
design art
very technical um way of um resolving
you know our art our artwork uh
of course it's a functional artwork
furniture's interior spaces
and
we started in 20209
we met at work and then
we have some commentary at work and
somehow our previous
employer told us that maybe we should
work together so
we
we started thinking about how we can
actually exhibit some of our work our
own creation uh in milan so that was
that more than ten years ago
so we left our full-time job and then we
started um you know
using all our heart and money and to
rent a space in a milan design with a
space in in the in the fair and uh we
spend a lot of money making prototypes
um showing our work
in an exhibition uh most designers shows
their work in this exhibition um
you know thinking about you know
who which producer which furniture brand
i can attract and then maybe this pieces
that i have made prototype is being
produced eventually so so we had this
dream back then when we first started um
naive
fresh
without much
you know
trouble
around us and there's no business or
financial trouble it's just like all
life-saving you know let's just do it
let's just make this do do this and then
make it happen but what exactly is going
to happen we do not know so so at the
point of time we were quite
fresh in that scent so we really put in
a lot of hard work we really had a lot
of fun making prototypes showing that
milan fare
for one
three years actually so
um
we got some prayers we got some uh
some kind of um recognition uh
eventually after three years we got an
award that's where we were awarded um
this um designers of the future by
design miami so it was given to
young designers that
practice in a way that
shows a certain discourse in modern
contemporary furniture design or object
design
so so given the award and we were asked
to design an installation so at the
point of time that was like the first
paid commission that we ever get
and uh we were happy that we didn't you
know screw up it was a nice installation
at the end which i'll share with you
later so so
the the forming of the studio it really
began there and uh working together in
the beginning wasn't so easy we have our
own separate thinking well our own
separate
you know way of perceiving what we
what we uh envision in each
each project each design but uh over the
first few years of working together
however i think we we travel together
we we look at the same thing and then we
start to
you know work in a way that we both
started to think a lot we both just
started to see the same thing and we
visit a lot of museums together
and uh eventually after a few years we
got together so we didn't start off as a
live partner
um we started off as a working partner
so so that um the synergy that we have
kind of brought us to you know
um
continue working together in in a way
that we have a relationship and then we
have a working
working relationship all together as one
um there is no work-life balance there
is no uh work is work after six years
you know life uh it's all together up to
now when we have a child we already have
a child uh work and life is still you
know
um very much
you know gel together um but i think
naturally we enjoy doing what we do
and we have always kept the process um
creative and not mundane and uh you know
just solving problems
so i think we enjoyed the work so much
that you know we could talk about work
even when we are cooking and when we are
child
but we don't exactly sit in front of a
computer
so this is our first office
uh which we first started we put in a
lot of money into you know renovating it
uh even my mom came to you know clean
the place for us
and uh in the first few years of our
time it was quite um
quite uh really a leap of faith
uh the rental of the space is really not
very high but there were a few months
that we really became very dry
financially and then we have to you know
kind of ask the landlord to you know can
i pay you uh next month this month's
renter so
um it was really a a matter of survival
time but unfortunately we were so lucky
that uh after we came back from
switzerland we exhibited in the design
miami exhibition we were
commissioned
with a few projects so that kept us
going and uh fortunately we are still
around so this is the first project
where we did um the first milan fair
that we participated in um
priscilla is the
is someone who is quite uh hands-on in
terms of modern making she enjoys making
a lot more
for myself i usually make the finite
prototype so there's a lot of refinement
in terms of his technical details are
all um done by me and she's the one who
usually makes a lot of models and she
explores the form and so this is
something that is quite um
quite quite um
unique in the sense that it's a
collection of small tables that are
meant to be put together in many
different configuration so this was what
was shown in milan in uh 2009 and uh
eventually it was produced by this um
italian brand called living dibani so up
to now is still in production
so every time living devaney sells a
sofa someone will buy a couple of this
table to to pair with the sofa
and uh
in the first few years we did some
exploration with lamps as well so during
that first few years um i think our
design thinking and our design
so-called
kind of start to synergize and start to
have this same train of thought in
rethinking about um typologies
about how the things how the form of
things are being shaped and how we could
use function to to determine a certain
form
so this is a dark lamb and a crane lamb
the one on the right screen lamp is tall
and it has articulative arm so
articulative head so the movement of the
lamp is actually restricted by its um
very limited angle
so it's something that's quite character
through quite a cartoon
and this was what we did for design
miami so it was really an idea of about
creating a space an intervention of um
we were given a brief which is uh having
conversation so the brief was
conversation
so to integrate conversation we are
thinking that you know to have a
compensation is not something that you
force someone to have or put people
together and you know force them to
communicate
and so we designed we did a
an installation of a space that is um
delineated with lines and then you're
free to come in and go out so it's
really quite an abstract way of uh
defining that brief
um
so this is what i did in um students
learn in the beginning
and yeah we are now you know married we
have a child and uh
work still carry on
um although we our work at life is you
know kind of together but we still you
know try to have
very well complementary
time that we give to our son
okay maybe i'll share with you a few
projects that i think is uh
in a way
punctuates a certain timeline in in
studio juju when it's formed until now
so in the beginning we had
a commission which is by
gardens by the bay to redesign the
seating experience in gardens by the bay
so
when it first opened in the beginning it
was
they bought a lot of furniture in the
haste so a lot of the furnitures that
they bought which are outdoor furnitures
are not really
meant to be in a tropical climate so a
lot of them very quickly they walk and
they are spoiled so they asked us to
reinterpret you know what is the sitting
experience in the garden so we came out
with a few
um
a few uh version of how the sittings exp
sitting experience could be in gardens
and they are all contextually designed
to be
working together with the context of the
garden in an architectural way
so
the the landscape which are already done
we try to reinterpret how these benches
could be
introduced into the space
and also i think the one of the main
thing about the the bench that we did is
to allow
the
hands to be replaceable uh over time if
they start to walk or rot
so this was done to be um and
kind of uh sit into this round floor
feature in the garden
and this is something that is very long
there is a line along the coastline
and there's a backrest version
and then you took the backrest version
and the long version you put them
together you get another new version
and this is along the um somewhere near
the entrance
so that's priscilla in my dog
and this is a small one within the
garden itself
and one there is a long circling along
the planter
so we we try to in a way
round the corners of the benches the the
planks
so that you know when you actually knock
it it doesn't brew so easily
and there's one very simple one along a
shelter walkway so this was the first
project that we did uh that is um
a kind of public that anybody could you
know sit on it or experience it
and the
in fact the very first project that we
were
um engaged
uh to be commissioned to do was actually
a art project by
lta
so when we first started renting our
office which is in the second year of
our studio we were curated to do and to
propose an art installation that is
permanent
for one of the downtown line station
so
we were given this station which is at
uh tampanese
so timpani's downtown line the architect
was a green kili so they are expert in
transport uh transit
um spaces like uh train stations and uh
you know in singapore and in australia
so this station was assigned to us and
we were so glad that you know this
station has really a vast amount of
space
which uh goes from the mezzanine to the
platform
so
the interesting part about this station
is actually the symmetry so there's a
lot of symmetry in this station the only
thing that differentiates the
the station one end to other was
on the left side there is a
leaf core on the right side there is a
staircase so that's the only two
different thing that you see in the
station otherwise it's exactly identical
on both sides
so we took to the advantage of this
station and how to integrate the artwork
quite in a way seamlessly with the
concept of the yellow wall that goes
across one end to our end to another
so we're thinking that
maybe a way to intervene into the space
is to describe how tall this station is
so we decided to do a very long shape
to describe how tall this is so in a way
when you're in the station you kind of
feel small but when you have an object
to bridge the relationship between you
and the space you start to feel that
okay this space is about this tall
because this object is so much taller
than me
so there is this in between the artwork
becomes in between you and the space
to allow you to understand you know the
context and the the skill of the space
so
this although this was done and uh
in the station so the station is
underground
so this is a view from the
one of the side and we also design a
bench that
replicates the form of the the artwork
on the other side we did a very big
round shape which is to describe how big
and fast this station is
so when you walk down the staircase you
find yourself
walking into the circle
and there is a nice mid
mid stair landing which you could stand
there and look at it if you have time
if not it would be interesting to see
someone walking up and then being inside
the circle so it's really quite an
experiential um
sculptural quality that engages you when
you
kind of um
transit up to the the top level
and also we design a
similar shaped looking bench
so in all these two sculpture on
different end of the station
functionally
it gives polarity to the space
so when you look at one side there's a
tall one on the other side there's a big
round shape so we want to give a sense
of polarity when commuters
travel
uh when they go in and out of the
station when they go up and down the
station they're able to see that you
know the polarity of left and right
yeah so that was one of the key uh
reason why you know the shape
was formed like that also
so this is one of the view from the top
and um yeah right right after this
project we we had our son
and uh when we were doing that project
actually
we started the project in 2011
and then the
the project actually finished in 2017
and then
2018 we had the sun
and uh
i think having a son having a child
for the first time really changes the
way we
we practice
especially
the our outlook in terms of the way we
worked uh time management
uh you know how much time you put into
the work
uh making a presentation like this today
you spend four hours on it or you could
spend you know four days on it so it
will give out the perspective how to
handle life and handle um
you know
another human being
so this is something interesting for us
as a couple who who works and live
together
um so while we have the baby we we got a
project uh we started doing interior
spaces
um
this is not the first interior space
that we did uh our first interior space
was actually uh interior space for oc
ocbc bank uh later on i will show you
the project um this is a project that we
did uh which is quite close to where we
lived so it's uh in great world city uh
it's actually for medical aesthetic
clinic that um
that focuses on you know the
beautification of
you know the human complexion and the
face
uh is where you give which is where you
go
go to for your botox
and uh you know whatever
so so the client is a
really really nice
couple also and um
they gave us a very open brief to create
an identity for them um not identity in
terms of branding more like an identity
in terms of a spatial experience
so
so the the client gave us a very open
brief to create a spatial experience and
uh no specific you know preference over
what it should be so we decided that you
know this
this is really a
a kind of um
opportunity to to create something that
is really distinct in terms of its brand
and how the space speaks for the brand
so we created a lot of curved walls and
then uh heavily textured walls to to
soften the way how light reflects off
the wall and uh the contrast is if you
are talking about aesthetic you are
talking about you know smooth uh
pristine uh luxury but then all we did
was to give it very coarse wall so the
client was actually quite um you know
hesitant in the beginning but eventually
they like the course wall because it
softens the way how the light
behaves on the wall reflects off the
wall
so
i think generally
both priests priscilla and i we
sometimes we consider ourselves a little
bit
of an artist more than a designer
sometimes just that we are both
industrial design trained and and we we
have you know good technical skill so
when we design the space this space
actually we treat it almost like an art
project where we actually we are
sculpting and putting together
curved shapes straight lines and the
thing about us being industrial design
train and designing interior space is
every single thing that we put into the
space
is for a good reason it's not just pure
aesthetic and
the the look
but um everything that we put in is for
a reason uh down to details like
you know can be quite boring but like uh
if you look at the the top wall here
there's a black gap this is where the
aircon supply icon supplies
so we know for sure that we do not like
like no technical looking
um
detailings on top like the air and
supply strips you know all the the light
light truss and stuff like that so we
want to hide all this detail
so almost like designing a product
so so those those walls are actually
done to really conceal the air
conditioning
and
the light
coves and stuff like that
and this is when you walk into the rooms
so there are few rooms that you walk
into
this is the
corridor and unfortunately when the
client
after we renovated the space just about
four months later the mall decided that
they want to go for an overhaul
so they started moving like tenants
around so after fall
i'm not sure if it's four to five months
of um
um
of their operation of business they have
to move to a new unit that's just a
couple units down
so
again we design the space that is kind
of similar but taking a chance to create
another way of interpreting the the
spatial narrative so
here we are um this time around with
even causal war
and um i mean we like how how the light
actually reacts on the
textured wall
and we were a really really good
contractor they managed to give us all
the quality that we're looking for when
we tried to soften like edges
corners curves yeah almost like an
almost like a sculpture
this is one of the room
so right after we finished this project
we were contacted by
health promotion bot
so
prior to this help a motion bot project
we actually did a interior space for
todd works which is a ui ux company that
is from chicago so they have an office
that's based in singapore and we did the
first thing the first office in in
singapore so
they somehow managed to you know uh
visit the office and
um the client actually told hp the help
of motionboard about us and then
here we are working on a project for
them
and uh it is actually to design a space
for
the
ui ux
department of uh help promotion bot
so so we get uh we got a space that is
uh of double volume which has another
part half of the space that sits into
the first story under the second story
so you get a very nice double volume
height which we
created a launch for it that's where
most of the events and gatherings happen
uh that's us
so we do it a lot we do a lot of our
custom
custom furniture for our space
and
we're running short time okay
so i'm just going to go very quickly to
show you the project
so a lot of the project that we do we
try to custom furniture with custom you
know
unique pieces for the space as well
so right after this project
it is covet so we went into this
one and a half year of like covet do's
and do not so we spent a lot of time
with our son making art projects at home
and then we managed to clean out the
office this is the neatest it can be
and finally after after like two years
of um kobit
we were invited to by this chan to do an
art installation at ndc together with
him
so this is a project called the road
chandelier
so it's really about
doing an art installation that kind of
reflects the creative process but by the
process is always a mess
and how we are able to freeze that
process
at the point of time whereby we need to
finish the project and the result is
something like this which we
you know we stopped after two days of
pulling ropes
and trying to figure out the space in
the atrium
um this is the project we did
it's a jewelry case
uh it was so in a moma
museum store for a while
this is for
a project
for wallpaper handmade
a couple of years back outdoors
heating
it's called chocolate so basically this
is like
part sculptural part furniture
interior space for ocbc we are initially
contacted to do the furniture only and
somehow the finisher became quite an
important part of the interior space and
then the client just asked us you can
design the interior space as well and we
did
and this was the furniture that we did
for the space
some chair exploration
uh
interior space as well
same project
some
furniture
objects
uh a lobby for bank of singapore
thank you very much
so this is what i have to share and i
think at the end of the day
having uh a partner to work together in
uh boho and life at the same time uh
it's really great like today i'm just
presenting uh just me because priscilla
is um off to pick up my son
so it's really great to have like you
know extension uh of course sometimes we
do have like a disagreement but end of
the day i think it's really about
putting down your ego and you know
pausing for a day or two and then think
about you know you know what's the best
for the situation and what's the best to
handle any problem that may come
uh yeah so i think this is this is all
thank you very much
thank you so much timo thanks for very
interesting presentation and sharing
your projects
uh okay so uh before we move on to the
last uh speaker of the day outer edit uh
i would like to remind everyone that you
are very welcome to ask any burning
questions to our speakers just enter
your question in the q and a chat box
and then we will
attend to your questions during the q
and a segment
we already have a few coming in so
so more more questions are always
welcome
so okay now uh to outer edit let me have
a short introduction
uh founded by ryan tan uh auto edit is
now co-piloted with his wife shamin tan
who is going to give the presentation
today
and for today's session they are the
only viewer who are actually driving a
team of designers
as opposed to
studio juju and
pai studio who are really just
husband-wife teams
so uh auto-edit uh they focus on
strategic branding
um and as a young design studio they
have gone from strength to strength so
today hopefully they will share with us
some of the secrets of their success
over to you shamin
all right thanks kelly uh if i start
also just wanted to say just really been
enjoying the sharing it's like really
beautiful and thoughtful concepts so and
design work so thanks victor jacqueline
and timo uh yeah so hi i'm sherman from
outer edit um ryan actually started
outer edit in 2011 and we're a creative
agency that's here to help friends make
me feel better
and then here's just a short video that
we made for our 10th anniversary to show
you some of what we've been up to since
the start
chocolates
[Music]
oh
when you give me
yeah so for us here at outer edit you
know we just believe in ideas that want
to be more we believe in brands that
want to be more and we believe in people
that want to be more
ultimately really the ones who thrive in
making meaningful maths in society so
what exactly is making meaningful matter
to us um it's
it's the idea of making meaningful
things and creation but more than that
it's also about just making meaning
matter more in contemporary society so
here are outside that we storytell
through brand strategy graphic design
and brand experiences if you look
through our work you find that it's
actually quite format and specific and
that's actually how we like it because
to us it's really about telling the
story and then selecting the best design
solution and format to fit that in the
most impactful way so whether that's
print uh there's digital or it's a
physical build or spatial experience or
maybe even like a format that we haven't
explored yet um and that we can make it
possible through collaborations you know
that's something that we really like to
do um it's not ryan calls beyond
disciplinary so we're constantly on the
lookout for new forms of expression as
well as like how we can collaborate and
learn from others to make that happen
so clients that we've been fortunate
enough to partner with it's a range you
know it's gone from big and small brands
local and global cell phone to public
companies
so this is our studio but currently
located at bukit paso road
it's our fifth studio so far when i
first joined on a very tiny windowless
whole space so i think this is the
nicest studio we've had by far and we
share it together with our team of 10 we
are made up of creative strategies
designers and account managers who we
call waymakers and we're just really
grateful to have
you know such
multifaceted individuals who are just
great at what they do game for creative
challenges and they stay open to
learning so like the video you saw the
stars actually created by our zebra
maker the account manager for ig
um
yeah so that's our team and then within
the team you have two of us uh it's ryan
and myself so ryan started the company
in 2011 and i joined in 2015. to be
honest i was actually going to i quit my
job i was going overseas to do uh
masters um and i was just like hanging
out at ryan's office to do some
freelance work so we were already dating
them and
how we met was that a friend
had wanted to introduce us for four
years and then we finally met at her
wedding
so anyway back to me hanging out at
ryan's studio so he had some jobs coming
in and he said like oh do you want to
help out so i was like okay yeah i'll
help out for a while and basically like
i never left and this is seven years
later and somewhere along the line we
got married as well
so i mean the question is like you know
is it a good idea to work with your
partner
um is it a match made in heaven
wow okay right then i will both tell you
the same thing but it is hard work
um the way we view it is like it's not a
match made in heaven but i'm sorry we
don't see a matching heaven like
a perfect match you know like any match
really requires like commitment
discipline and patience to make it work
and the match made in design requires
all of that too and sometimes even more
because there are weeks on end sometimes
that will be together 24 7.
um
but you know it's a match that through
this crucible of working together and
playing and living and parenting too
we have just strengthened and deepened
so
has being together and working together
made our life more meaningful then i
would say yes to that
so there have been a lot of disagreement
tears and learning that's social but you
know we've also had a lot of joys
together um we had our baby as well uh
she's 10 months this year and we also
have two cats that we really love to be
going great and they keep us singing
during the pandemic
yeah
so just a bit more i guess about you
know being working together and that
match and design i think you
don't go into it like expecting it to be
a bit of roses um you kind of learn what
it takes to make things work and it's a
constant process of just
learning it and relearning it as people
evolve naturally but if you just focus
on making it meaningful then you really
learn how to make it fulfilling as well
so that's a similar attitude that we
bring to our work as well
um okay so today i'm just gonna give you
a quick flavor of what we do if there's
anything that you've seen on website ieg
that you're curious to know about like
feel free to ask later
yeah and here's some of the work that
i'll be showing you
so the first one is um the good
intentions calendar 2022 uh for rj paper
and we did it also with our closed
printer
collaborator allegro print
so uh rj calendar sorry rg paper
actually has done calendars for the last
30 years and over those 29 years they've
you know the impressive rosters of
creators so when they asked us when they
wanted to do the calendar we were like
yeah yeah we want to do it but then we
were also a bit stressed about like okay
what are we going to do to be able to
make a difference to this print calendar
you know beyond the functional aspect of
the calendars being there and telling
you dates like how can we create
something that will allow people to
enjoy every day
something that's fresh interesting and
fun
so
what the team did was that they actually
explored and then they looked at the
mobile greeting messages that we always
received from our parents and they kind
of sent you in the morning and then the
text is a bit um there's usually a typo
and then there's some flowers behind or
some beautiful scenery
well just
beyond what they look and sound like
there's no doubt that you know the
intention behind such messages are very
very positive and the warmth and the
love that they convey when this is sent
to you
so in my yeah
sorry i was going to say my mom sends
them to me every single morning so i
feel the love but anyway how do we
capture this spirit and do it in an
elevated way that was uh
that was a starting point for us to
go on to this concept of the calendar so
that's how the good intentions calendar
for us came about
so we really enjoyed this project with
rj people in the league girl
our team actually did all the custom
illustrations so really proud of them
for that
yeah the account is just full of custom
um
illustrations and easter eggs as well
and i think what was nice was that you
know all the collaborators that came in
just brought something to the table uh
you know i knew was seeing like what
kind of different papers we could use
and then allegro came in and said like
hey why don't you you know cmyk right
now should change out the m to a neon
and then let's see what that produces
and okay okay like let's try it you know
i mean we did way more test prints than
i think anyone expected but uh it turned
out well so that was something fun and
something that we've learned along the
way as well
uh the next project is street of clans
this was a anchor
program for singapore design week in
2019 um it was a district activation and
what we wanted to do was we wanted to
celebrate like the angel clan values of
kinship and unity
in this creative festival
so
book a parcel street is also the street
that we are on and we are actually in
the clan house the co-clan house
and we felt like they had so much
heritage so much stories but a lot of
times it was a very
close i guess
community that people didn't cn2 and
it's not that they wanted it to be like
that it's just that they never maybe had
the opportunity to share further so when
the district activation or precision
activation came about we were like okay
what can we
what can we do to help and how can we
make this uh an enjoyable time but also
something that's really meaningful
so we
start off with the concept of
bringing together the clan values
of kinship unity lending a helping hand
we created a whole festival branding and
then we also created programming for it
and we also matched up um different
collaborators
different creatives sorry to collaborate
uh within the space of the clan house to
do artistic installations
we also got some other creators uh
illustrators such as adai sput to
collaborate with the local businesses on
the street that come back
and
yeah there are a lot of other things as
well i think we had 90 over
collaborators in the end where we
initially thought we would have about 20
collaborators and this was the result
[Music]
hello
right
[Music]
yeah i think someone really made this
very meaningful for us um it was just
like making
i guess design relevant to communities
that otherwise would have no reason to
actually interact with design
and you know when we brought in the
collaborators and to work with other
stakeholders the clients fmb businesses
all our neighbors on the street then
they said like oh wow this is uh you
know
like different con
communities that had never uh
been exposed to each other before and
through that i mean there were also new
relations that came about so that was
really nice and i think way a journalist
from manhattan he actually said like
stream of clans showcase the
transformative power of design so that
was just something really nice to
hear and just keep us going because it
took a lot of late nights as well it
took a lot of work to get there together
with the team
to do this so yeah really grateful for
the experience
okay um archifest branding uh briefs a
bit through this uh but this was the i
know festival um and we rendered it for
last year uh i think one of the
challenges for it was that it was moving
into a native digital format and that
was the first time that it was
like completely virtual courses at the
high epidemic as well so
that was something that we had to think
about when we were designing you know
how do you create an identity that would
be flexible that would you know really
be able to
showcase um and feature all the
different speakers all the different uh
aspects of this festival and look good
uh online as well as through the
different platforms
then lastly just to finish up with two
projects from millennial walk so
millennial has been the client that
we've worked with for
maybe
it's been
six
to seven years already and we're really
grateful i think over the years the
relationship has really grown uh and
deepened uh and they let us try
different interesting things like oh
let's build a christmas tree our
scaffolding you know and they don't
block too much edit yeah so we've done
the christmas tree for five years uh
this was in 2019 as well and we wanted
2019 going on to 2020 to be a year that
celebrated a lot of connections and that
was the concept behind this 13 meter
tall christmas tree
so i think every year for the christmas
uh
campaign in millennium what we try our
best to do something different to do
something that resonates for the year as
well
all right and the most recent project
from millennium is happy park
so
we wanted to create a non-seasonal
concept this time around to last beyond
the fastest season um it's really in
response to today's fast changing war
and i think everything that's happened
in the last few years like
you know how do we remind ourselves just
to be intentional how do we
slow down and choose joy among any
circumstances and i think especially in
the design industry it's just so easy to
run fast run hard and
you know just totally burn out and we've
been there before as well and you know
it's not something that we want to do
for the rest of our lives so
i mean doing such projects like the good
intentions calendar doing the lenovo
happy part um the wellness that one has
to have in your life and the wellness
that you have to have in all aspects of
your life like whether it's play or it's
work it's something that resonates a lot
with us and it's something that we hoped
to really learn about
in the team and as well as our personal
lives
yeah so if you're interested uh this is
until
may mid may and then you can take a look
at it
so yeah that's a bit about us uh at the
heart of it we just strive to make
meaningful matter whether it's at work
at play with your teammates your friends
your family like i'm grateful for those
vans circles they actually intersect for
me so sometimes that makes it easier um
and also leave you like a quote that one
of our directors adelia mentioned in an
internal meeting recently and then ryan
mentioned it to me as well it was a
simple one it was just you know how will
today change tomorrow so what can you do
today to make your life in all the
different aspects like more meaningful
and fulfilling
yeah
so thanks studio sml kelly and the team
from dsg felicia and cheryl uh and yeah
thanks everyone who tuned in and spend
time with us to listen to this
thanks so much shamin thanks for the
interesting transition
may i invite all the other speakers to
turn on your video we are going to have
uh the q a segment we already have quite
many questions coming in so uh
let me
start with the maybe the earlier ones um
okay
um so i think quite a lot of people are
interested in this kind of husband and
wife set up
so the first question here is to all of
you
um how do you guys solve creative
differences
it is already hard between just
colleagues how do you manage
so maybe we'll do fly and then timor
energy
okay um
i guess as i was alluding to at the end
of the presentation
um
i guess we we are trying we try to
create more of a neutrality between the
two of us when it comes to
work and the creative output
and also because i think
for our discipline we do see it as a
kind of
objective and rational discipline
so
somehow this this operative framework
that i talked about which encompasses
the various kind of methodologies that
was briefly explained as well it kind of
isolated any kind of major differences
between between ourselves so we we don't
really get really personally
i guess emote emotional about about the
projects it's really
you know just plug into this this we are
working testing it out across
the various scales of projects to see
how far we can stretch the
the kind of thinking and then
um and then hopefully in doing so we we
always operate on a much more neutral
kind of territory without really
getting too personal about things but of
course we
we do have
um you know we do acknowledge our our
individual strengths and weaknesses and
then we tend to let go if we feel that
the other person is better at this
particular aspect of the design process
or whatever so i think maybe
you know through the years we have
managed to
um
to kind of avoid any so-called major
differences yeah and hopefully
uh we are on something
interesting and of course we're
constantly trying to
um develop and practice uh as well
based on the idea
okay
um
timor how about uh you and chris
uh
unfortunately i may not may not be able
to
answer the question or solve that
problem because
i think in a very surrenderitious way
and both priscilla and i we are quite
alive
in terms of the way we approach
creativity
so
but sometimes we do have arguments about
how to approach
uh certain things or how to handle
certain projects or how to um you know
resolve certain things so we we do have
differences in the way we
we handle projects or develop projects
um i mean we do have argument definitely
but uh
at the moment is easily resolved
uh we always use time as the gauge we
use time as the the tool the resolve
that's that the difference so a lot of
times for example if we would not see
eye to eye on certain things
we will just you know not talk about it
and then maybe
a day or two later
come back to it and
most of the time i'm the one who will
tell her oh yeah i think you're right
maybe just do it that way do it your way
so i think a lot of times it's really
about a certain kind of very personal
ego and wanting to
assert your your idea or
your solution or what you think might be
correct or best for certain things but
maybe anna is not so i i guess that is
really
something to do with uh team playing so
in a scenario about you have much more
like
a 10 10 10 team or you you work in a
corporation that has like 20 people
i think it's the same thing sometimes
you just have to resolve
uh certain things by
and not you know talking over someone
over and over again to assert your
your ideas so i think for us it works
quite well like that
yeah
to to use time now as the tool
uh but creatively we don't have like big
arguments
yeah i mean we have more arguments about
the child and the work
yeah
okay thanks uh shamin maybe for you
besides uh sharing with us how you
resolve creative differences with brian
you can also maybe share with us like in
terms of like managing your team when
there are creative differences how do
you uh resolve it
nice i mean i was gonna say the two
actually overlapped a bit but i just
wanted to say nice about what timo said
yes listening goes very far i am
sometimes guilty of that when i when i
have a strong opinion right i'm just
like i'm quite sure i'm right right but
then ryan is equally stubborn so that
does not make a good combination but
thankfully over the years as we have
gone through this i think we've um
smoothen it out more especially at work
yeah at home sometimes you know new
situations but at work yes we smoothen
it out so
it's really i think just respecting each
other and then listening to what each
other has to say because there's usually
some truth in each other's opinion and
if we really cannot um
like if we really cannot come to an
agreement on what we think is best right
that's actually when
like if this will work then we will we
will bring in our team to actually
understand their opinions and it's not a
matter of like oh who are you citing
it's really a matter of like as they are
experts in their own right like what do
they see from their perspective um and
then understanding that to then make the
decision with more information as well
and in terms of managing the team i
think
we're quite fortunate i mean our team
everyone is
very nice
all our creators i feel like they
they are open to any feedback they're
good at what they do and they
don't have any ego um so
yeah so when it comes to brainstorming
and working with each other then i think
everyone just respects to bring
their opinions to the table and if it's
different then we agree to disagree and
then um
based on you know what is
the brief and what is the solution to
answer the brief then we make the best
decision it's not something that should
be subjective
thank you okay we have an interesting
question here um as a husband and wife
team
how do you all manage the finances
how are the finances kept separate
between firm and family
or each other
number one
you should know that better than anyone
kelly
okay
uh jack and think maybe i'll start first
so so we were just we were just joking
about this when we read the question
right we said that if this was entitled
match made in business we will probably
have very little slides to show
so luckily it's not it's match made in
design right so so we don't really have
to talk about that part but um
the other day we were just talking about
how bad our bouquet thing is
[Music]
so it's it's it's interesting i think
it's definitely interesting to put it
out on the table because uh as what
teemo timo was alluding to just now like
when we first started out there is that
naivety of really just putting your
entire um all your eggs into one basket
right everyone just starts out with this
thinking that oh it's going to be a
bit of roses and everything is just so
idealistic at the start um
you know your first year you're together
and then you have a practice and
but i guess it's it's like with
everything there's always the the bumps
along the road and um
it's the same running a business so
i think i don't i don't feel that
there's anything
different in in
the fact that we are
married to run a business together i
think it's probably the same even if you
were just partners with someone that
you're not married to i think running a
business is just so tough
especially as design practices somehow
we we do not have that dna to deal with
businesses in a certain way so um
i mean it helps that we are we are also
life partners so i think there's a
certain shorthand in understanding um in
terms of
our appetite for risk our appetite for
what takes
what it takes to kind of like drive the
business so and also our individual
strengths i suppose as personalities in
the business so
um
so i think
from from our point of view um
it is uh definitely
linked like the whole
fact that financially how you are i
guess also um is
represented as as as a couple both as a
couple as well as in the business but um
it helps that you're a couple i think
because
you already know
um your sort of
[Music]
type of person i guess in terms of like
how how
how how much like finance must be
yourself as a
as a person
if you know i mean i think it's kind of
difficult to explain
okay until we got the gist of it
maybe timon you want to share about your
family's money matters
becoming this is becoming like a channel
5 money matters
thing
for the two of us when we have this we
have a role to play and quite naturally
we ease into that role of uh priscilla
is always the one who
you know look at the finances and say oh
you know we need we need to top it up we
need this amount of money we need
a familiar team yeah so i'm the one who
thinks okay how should we get the money
you know do we do this we do that you
know what project we know how do we
build client
and stuff like that we talk about this
mean all the time
and uh
because of our nature we we kind of ease
into that that role
yeah and uh priest is always the one who
is
you know
you know we need this we need this we
need this we need to pay for this
you know all the piano and stuff that so
naturally she's the finance person and
the one who is working on the project
and
thinking about you know how much should
we charge the client so that i can
satisfy your bank account
so yeah we have we have this natural
role to play so it's quite complimenting
and uh how do we keep finances between
uh the firm and family uh i mean
actually the
there's not there's no
how or you know methods it's just two
separate accounts
yeah
so
you you just need to constantly balance
between how much you know the
the the financial health of the
companies
and you know how much you need to manage
your family your your you know your life
and then how much
you know finance financially your your
company should be bringing in and
how to upkeep the company and then good
enough that it keeps your life so
actually it's so simple when when it's a
very small outfit
and
i mean we always talk about how how to
bring in more
money and how to invest that money in
growing the company in certain ways it
could be going in terms of team size it
could be going in terms of
wearing another hat so nowadays as
designers we kind of need to wear a
different different hat already so we're
talking about
um giving design consultancy to to
clients we're also thinking about
starting our own brand
so so we we might be trying to do that
and to to manage the finance of the
company becomes even more important at
this moment whereby we are trying to
diversify what we are doing
yeah so
so
firm and family very easy just two
accounts
yeah keeping it clean is the best
okay thanks uh xiaomi how about you and
ryan how do you guys
ensure that your financial matters uh
you know it doesn't get in the way of
the partnership
i still do what team will mention ours
is too very strictly separate because i
think also a bit of a different
situation because obviously anything
that the company brings in is also money
that well in the sense is
with our team so
that's the responsibility that we hold
ryan is the one that manages the
finances more and he looks at it
together than accountants
okay thank you guys uh okay the next
question is um
thank you all for sharing it's
heartening to see thoughtful and
articulated thoughts behind the designs
what would you feel are some of the
philosophy and influences that have
shaped your practices
okay
so again maybe we start with uh jack
um
yeah i think um
in terms of philosophy and influences i
think
it's it's probably also very
circumstantial the way we have
decided to practice
in this way and also to remain
as largely a small firm
after kind of going through
working with companies of various sizes
i think we naturally
prefer a more hands-on approach to
creating our work we enjoy the autonomy
that comes with the territory of running
your own
practice uh it it also kind of allows us
to stay more
sort of lean and nimble really to adapt
you know to to different situations and
all that so it's also a very practical
way of
looking at how
how you kind of you can kind of control
your output versus
you know the cost that you have to you
know put in into staff costs rentals and
things like that um so it could
naturally develop into a way of working
as as i was trying to share doing the
the explanations about the various
projects and the slides that it's really
developed
you know into a way of working for us
being
um you know largely across the 13 years
that we are you know
in business now largely on a good number
of those years we are essentially
a two-person core team working with a
group of you know collaborators from
time to time
interns and stuff that come in and out
but it's essentially just really working
through
the operative systems that we're trying
to set up and to constantly fine tune
and hone that craft
yeah so i think that really has a key
impact on
how we work how we design how we think
okay thanks uh timo how about yourself
philosophy and influences that have
shaped your practice very difficult to
answer because
both of us we design together and
usually our conversations are not very
philosophical
we visit a lot of museums a lot of art
mission uh different kind of places we
travel the world together we look at the
same thing uh a lot of inspiration and
influence are you know things that we
see together things that we uh
experience together and uh i mean after
10 more than 10 years of practice i we
still couldn't you know come down to
this you know
what's our philosophy and the way we
have been influenced i guess it's a very
personal um
um experience that we have together that
when we are
we're gonna approach a certain project
or certain um design or even the way we
approach our practice it's actually
quite fluid but at the same time it's
not loose because it we we have a
certain set of methodology
that design methodology that we we have
uh to approach each project and uh a lot
of times it's really about
the context where a piece of furniture
is or the place
a place that we are designing what are
the surrounding elements and who is it
for so
it's a very industrial design kind
of thinking yeah that the context is
very important the user the experience
so we we designed with a lot of um ideal
experience in mind what kind of
experience uh each design would give to
the user so it's a methodology that
guides us in our design the outcome the
way it looks um the way it works
sometimes it's quite
self-reflective and it's always a
recollection of things that we see and
experience together
i mean i would say it's experience that
we have gained over the years but to put
into a line of what philosophy it is
it's quite difficult for us to you know
pinpoint
thanks uh xiaomi how about you and right
um i think for us besides fake
meaningful matter which obviously
anchors
all of it uh i would say it's
probably the dna
of the collaborative dna that started
out when ryan first started off after
edit as a t-shirt company so what they
would do would be they would uh engage
different creatives all over the world
in like barcelona japan singapore
malaysia and they would play creative
ping pong whereby one person was on a
piece of um design work and then pass it
on and people would add all and then
they would smash it up so i think just
you know reaching out to other creators
and playing in that manner is something
that has translated through even until
today so our projects like pioneer
portraits where we got in 23 other
illustrators to do like a visual
timeline um
along orchard road um for the different
singaporean milestones during sg50 or
even like street of claire's where
there's collaboration or when we do
like when we do the hospitality suites
like singapore suite and international
suite um during act one then we do enjoy
bringing other collaborators and giving
them like a platform uh to showcase as
well whether they are emerging or
whether they are established so
collaboration is something that also
guides us in the work that we do
okay thanks uh
so uh there's one targeted question at
you um
or rather a question targeted at you uh
what will be
outer edit
usp
compared to other branding creative
agency
what are the value proposition on how
auto edit take on
the creative path
like difficult question i've eaten my
dinner yet because i need some brain
power okay let me think about it oh okay
i would say it's
i think it's going back to our anchoring
and how we prefer to
focus on like the storytelling um
so you know because it's focused on the
storytelling and the idea of it and
you know how you translate that
narrative it's not so as i mentioned
it's not so much format specific
so
so i think that actually uh is the usp
because sometimes clients might come in
and say like okay can you do a
publication for me or can you do a
website for me but the what we go back
with is you know
depending on what it is uh you want to
say and who it is you want to reach out
to then that format might not be the
best way forward for you and we help
them to realize this and also to make it
happen so i think that thinking um and
that journeying alongside with them then
is something that um
i mean increasingly we have realized
that this is what the clients also come
back to ask for and of course the
relationships that i'll be along the way
okay thanks another question for you
the question is hello chamin with a
bigger team under you
how does the husband and wife dynamic
come into play when managing your stuff
okay
i'll be very honest i mean it took a
while for us to really find our groove
for this especially with a bigger team
um we had some teammates that have been
with us for seven years hi rachel yeah
so they've been very patient seeing us
grow from like two people to like five
to you know and more than that and
it's tricky at the start because when
you start off and you have skill sets
that overlap you naturally just want to
bring that equally because you feel like
you should be playing an equal role
in the company
for with each other
but then as time goes by then you at
least for us we learned that
um
you know you play to your strengths as
well so
even when it comes i think um and i i
guess is managing or leading or just
really working alongside our teammate i
do think our hierarchy is quite
flat like we
do know what our roles are
um
but it's not like the intern can't tell
ryan like i want to get into a
brainstorming conversation like you can
um yeah but
sorry my point was coming back to it is
um
okay i actually lost my point just in
one moment
see like no dinner is like this uh
oh yeah yeah yeah okay so over the years
as we honed it right so we realized that
each of us take to our strengths and we
have different things that we're good at
so when it comes to believing people
that's also something that we have
realized um and therefore
you then specialize a bit more in that
and then you just respect the other
person so right now like ryan leads um
the creator and design team uh together
with our team leads as well and then
that's something that i follow that i
don't step into so much when he needs to
make the decision then he makes the
final decision together with that input
and then for myself like with the
waymakers and with other aspects maybe
like hr aspects of the company then
that's when ryan
um
would kind of like
see to maybe what seeds probably that
would but would probably like hear out
what i have to say as to what i think is
the best way forward and he will
naturally just say like okay like let's
go ahead and that sounds like a good
idea
thank you hope that answers it i'll give
you a break now now we'll go to
timo there's a question for you
timo thank you for sharing such diverse
projects
what are your thoughts
do you feel art and design are connected
yes essentially design is applied arts
so
things that you see around you i mean
they help you to
understand the world around you much
better
it allows you to engage with me in
the world
so i do see art and design um connected
but if you're talking about the practice
of design and exactly how one will
approach design
because it's not just you know art
within you know the course of work um
but i think design becomes art becomes a
very good or important influence in uh
the creative process
so i mean i i say this because um
through the course of my work i travel a
lot and i visited a lot of things and i
see a lot of like works of art and stuff
like that
and i think it was important it is
important how it has influenced me the
way i look at it
and
particularly both priscilla and i we are
in terms of practice we are more
inclined towards um
you know
practicing like an artist
so so to me it's it's quite um connected
in that sense
yeah i mean if you are talking about
uh
example if you are a doctor
if you are a doctor
if you are influenced by art i think it
does a great deal to the way you look at
your practice as a doctor as well
especially if you're a static doctor
yeah
so i think that influence is important
even an engineer could be a great
great artist even
an actor is an artist so i think the
appreciation of beauty that is just you
know it's beyond
you know what is nice or is not nice but
art allows you to understand the world
much better allows you to understand the
condition of people the condition of
things and places much better so i think
it's important that uh i mean we do i
mean all of us
uh you know
understand art a little bit better
so yes i feel connected
thanks
um i have a question for you guys uh
because i also run a small studio so uh
my question is that for small studios i
think one of the challenges that i face
which i believe maybe you guys also face
the same is a retention of stuff
uh you know in a small studio if you
hire two or three person no promotional
prospects
in terms of pay we can pay as high as
the big studios
um so of course shamin has successfully
retained someone for seven years so
congratulations he must be doing a good
job uh but juju and clive you know both
of you guys are operating as a
just you know two-person team so i
believe you might have some challenges
that maybe you can share about like how
do you think we as small studios can
overcome this problem
um
yeah that's a that's a very interesting
question because i think it true i mean
we probably have
um
quite similar experiences that we have
shared as well and
we we do find it difficult to
um
to make people subscribe to a similar
sort of uh
way of looking at practice if you will i
think because um being being a very
small studio i think in a way
we become almost an an entity or not in
ourselves right so i think that could
also be a bit difficult for people to
get into so i think for for sure mean it
was very nice to hear that
you also do a lot of collaborations with
other studios um and then for us as well
i think we try as much as possible even
though as a small studio
existing on our own we try to
collaborate as much as possible
so
i think that's one way to maybe attract
or to
to spread
our philosophy or our way of working
with a larger sort of platform of people
that hopefully i don't know might might
find synergy in how we work together
um
you know whether it's a good thing or
bad thing to stay this size right um we
talked about it we talked about how
um
as a small studio there's always this
push and pull thing about where do you
want to really grow to something that is
bigger because then you end up being
more of managing
the people that uh that are with you
running the studio rather than being
focused on the things that you really
like doing um so for us and i'm sure for
the rest of the creatives as well being
creative and being like at the thick of
it is usually
the things that we find most enjoyable
and that's why we set up a studio on our
own
so
partly
i don't know i mean that's what effector
said partly it's due to the size that we
are and the size that we want to be that
forces us i guess to
to work in a certain way to develop a
certain framework of working so that we
don't actually have to grow too big
a team in order to do the kind of work
that we really want to do
so i guess that's that's our way of
dealing with it
i think i think maybe it would be
interesting to hear from other people
how they deal with it yeah actually my
the question i asked was it's also
related to a question that just came in
any thoughts about future expansion of
the company uh through the addition of
partners so for jack i guess it's a no
unless our child wants to take over
which i don't think they will
i actually have a last question about
that okay wait we'll come to that later
so uh tim also uh maybe your thoughts
about retention of staff and also
any possible extension of the company
uh
i think
we don't have a problem retaining stuff
because we always have one stuff
i mean when we started we we just the
two of us and then in between
uh up to just like uh about one or two
years ago we always had one stuff and
then now just the two of us again
and uh i mean like what jack say we are
very handsome people who enjoy what we
are do what mean we are doing we set up
the studio to you know to be able to
practice in a way that we're very
hands-on
and if the day do come that you know we
are just managing people i don't think
you'll enjoy it
and and if any were to happen
in that sense i don't think the studio
will last or produce the kind of work
that i mean we are producing
uh work that we are happy about
um
so i don't think we will be expanding
um i mean now the challenge is um when
we have projects is always very diverse
uh we have interior projects
um
interior spaceship planning projects we
have furniture project
objects project various kind of project
art projects so we are so diverse that
we couldn't fit like you know uh hiring
someone who does an interior project and
not able to give him you know
the next interior project after he's
finished with that project
so we are always constantly struggling
to hire someone who is like you know
jail or trade
but you know this this person will never
come
so so a lot of time we work with
contract designers for you know half a
year
or a few months or depending on the
project the length of the project so we
do that and in order to be still very
hands-on on every project
uh i mean if the day do come whereby we
we want to expand uh financially to
expand you know our capability to in
terms of business i don't think we will
want to expand studio
you know like i say um before that um i
think nowadays designers like us we we
have to try to wear different hats yeah
so it could be you know doing setting up
another business
running it together along with studio
juju and making things work basically
so but to dilute the studios worked uh
not really because it
is with beginning set up to just be the
two of us
yeah
creatively
so
i mean we are quite fluid and free about
it but at the same time we know
you know we we wouldn't expand beyond
maybe one or two person uh extra
additional to the two of us okay thanks
okay shall we so maybe now you should
share with us the secrets of how you
managed to keep your stuff for seven
years
and yeah so any plans for uh even
extending outer edit further
i mean i think staff retention yeah it's
not an easy one
for small companies um i guess
i mean we've also had our fair share of
like you know people coming people
leaving as well um but i mean i hope
that everyone who comes in and you know
leads us also leaves us with something
that they've gained yeah so as long as
they've done their best when us i think
that's what we really look out for
um
[Music]
i'll get to like how we
we like what we can offer as a small um
agency to actually retain but i also
just want to mention i think ryan has
talked about this a few times before
whether to expand or not to expand but i
guess size doesn't always determine
success as well but we have been told
that sometimes for the projects that we
do you know it punches above the weight
and clients are surprised to find that
well only a team of then maybe six or
ten and i mean even i look at the work
at studio choo choo and apply um
like students doing it's just like
amazing work right it's just like
i mean it's just beautiful work so yeah
size really doesn't determine success um
and as to how you can possibly retain
people as a small agency
i feel like we're still learning this
and i think kelly you run it
successfully for so many years so we
should actually be asking you the
question um
but the things that have worked for us i
think is really just listening to your
people right listening to what it is
that they want what is it do they want
for their future so that they can build
that future with you as well so i think
a lot of times what we heard on our site
is that people enjoyed the culture um at
our company they you know enjoyed the
care that was given they enjoyed the
projects even that was being done but
you know the pace of the creative
industry is very harsh sometimes and
you're just running project after
project especially when you're a larger
sort of larger company because
not you can't say like okay let's all
take a break at this point in time right
you have to cover the overheads you have
to cover the rent um even during the
pandemic was really really hard you
still have to pay all the salaries and
you're just looking at your finances
looking very red and going down and
you're like oh my gosh like what's gonna
happen and then the titanic lasts for
two years they're like are we gonna make
it so it has been a hard period to be
honest and i'm thankful that ryan and i
have both been together uh through it
and our team has also really like pulled
through it with us so i think at the end
of day yeah
what i think helps people stay if you
understand what is they want and as a
small company you're actually more
flexible you can make that happen
um
if we like recently i think we augmented
our welfare policies we just asked
around me us
i mean i just asked like people who are
from bigger companies people tick top
people who work for you know mnc's
overseas company i said you know what
the top three welfare policies that you
truly uh you truly like enjoy and
resonate and so many of them just said
birthday leave and i'm just like you
know birthday leave is something we
totally can give no and then we had um
we had medical benefits and then we had
like separate benefits for the team um
but then i heard like oh flexy benefits
is actually what some people want so
like sure you know we'll just lump it
together we'll give 500 up a year and
you can just use it for your dental your
medical your welfare um so yeah it's
really listening and i think committing
to wanting to change so even if the
industry doesn't work for you ryan likes
to tell me this as well at the end of
the day we are creators and we are
solution makers as well so if we want to
figure out how to make the industry a
better place how to make it a place
where we can see ourselves working in 20
years down the road see ourselves
working in it as parents as well then
we're exactly the right people to make
this change as well
thanks jack you can consider flexi
benefits from victor
[Laughter]
yes yes he cannot get the next bottle of
wine
okay guys uh well coming to the end of
the session i just have one last
question to wrap up the session so all
of you have kids
okay so uh what if one day
your child come up to you and like ah i
want to be a designer
what would be your reaction or advice to
them
great
where's my where's my carton of wine to
drown my sorrow or you will prepare the
cutter a wife or your kid
no
[Music]
actually i think our kids
well
our kids have survived so um a word of
advice to studio juju and and uh and
also i did well our kids are already in
their teams so they have survived the
toddler years and they have survived
throughout um i think
for us really it was it was really nice
to have our own practice when they were
growing up because during the formative
years it was very nice for them
to really be part of our lives like
literally they were taken along for site
visits they were taken along with us
whenever we had to do snagging at
clients houses and all that and it was a
very um
it was almost a seamless sort of um
uh combination of family and work in
that sense so
um
maybe by osmosis they are already in
this like
design
training from from birth and
it's quite natural i think for us to
talk to them about what we do
[Music]
at work and i think they have a sense of
what's happening as well so in a way
that's i i really appreciated those
first early few years that we had the
luxury of of being able to spend the
time with them whenever we wanted to
um
so so that was that was very nice
so yeah i think i wouldn't really say no
if they wanted to be a designer yeah i
think for me as well i really i would
just encourage them to go for
whatever they feel is right right um
they don't have to be
you know in the industry or in the
creative field just because we are
in in this industry
so it's really where where their heart
takes them and and where the interest
lies so i think it's also
for us
uh a bit too early to tell
you know where each of them are heading
i mean we have two girls so
um yeah i'm not really stressing over it
actually here
thanks uh timo how about you
uh i will say okay lol
[Laughter]
there's no business to take over
at this moment i've never thought of you
know whether is it okay or if you ask if
you say that you know he wants to be a
designer i mean i mean as long as he
likes it as long as he's good at it
yeah i mean at this moment he's four uh
he's quite creative with words
so he tweets his words he uses words on
me that are you know pretty creative to
to make me angry or you know to use
certain to say certain things to me
i don't know he's just very good with
words lah yeah so i mean he does have a
politician
yeah maybe politics
so he doesn't really like to draw so
much
yeah but he likes the pain on his body
so
i mean as kids you find all ways of i
mean all ways to
you know be creative and i think it's
important to be creative
but you know he doesn't have to end up
being a designer or
or an artist or what he could be anybody
he wants to be
so i think this is what
priscilla and i both think
you know um just need to be creative
i mean a copywriter or it could be a
politician politician also need to be
creative right
so yeah
that's what we think okay thanks how
about xiamin
i think she's only 10 months at the
moment so i think her end goal is more
like i want to eat the apple rather than
what's my livelihood but if she didn't
want to become a creator
i guess i could ask her
to do two things um
one maybe is just
do at least like two internships at
different um design practices just to
truly understand what it's like to be a
creative and then
yeah make sure she gets really immersed
in that the other one might actually be
now ryan and pixie um
have actually done this industry survey
called dominif
and
so i know it sounds like a plot but i
will really ask her to do this uh and
they've just released like the first
inaugural book whereby they surveyed
like
like the design industry and it does
talk about like you know what the in the
design industry is like like
the overtime or like do people see
themselves being in here like 20 years
down the road like what's the pay gap
between men and women so like she reads
that you know um and she
she is fully informed to make her choice
then yeah totally welcome it and i think
that would be the same for like any path
that she decides to choose um i mean i
don't know i haven't done this parenting
thing for very long it's just been 10
months i'm just holding on to the advice
that my friend said just keep your baby
alive for one year so i would probably
uh look at jacqueline and victor and
even timo and priscilla to
see what's the best way to actually like
encourage your child to
just explore what it is that they truly
enjoy
okay thank you so much all of you uh i
think we probably uh have to end now we
have uh kind of like overrun quite a bit
uh thankfully thank you so much uh pie
studio architects sudo juju and outer
edit uh for spending time with us today
so now i'm going to hand over to felicia
of uh design singapore
thank you kelly victor jacqueline timo
and sherman for taking the time to join
us today and for sharing your
experiences so candidly with us it's
been so great to hear from all of you
and to our attendees thank you for
staying with us to the end of this
session we know you've overrun a little
bit but so grateful that you're still
here with us
so more in-depth interviews with our
speakers can also be found on steel
smells website along with podcasts on
their spotify channel so if you're keen
to find out more you can scan the qr
codes that you see on your screen
and studio sml's accompanying exhibition
abstract creatures is also currently
showing at the singapore university of
technology and design till first june so
if you're in the area do check that out
as well you can also watch a documentary
of the project by scanning the qr code
that you see on the right and if you'd
like to find out more programs about the
at the national design center you can
scan the qr code that you see on your
right so this is where we'll leave you
now so thank you once again for joining
us and thank you to our speakers again
and we hope to see you at our future
events
take care goodbye